ios 社長です今日はとある戦いのために大阪に来ておりますですが挑戦するのは僕
ではありません
このどこです
レース
はい研修ですでっきょとーん何をするかと言いますと阿部が pv の曲で何すかは
剣心風知ってくる沢東可能となぜか天使選手にロック寝具で買ったら
一戦毎ず企画がありましてこれめっちゃって言ってると思ったんですけどあんまず出
なかったよバダが出なかった米文学からね
何だろういい気しかし僕も来ねぇねぇ
見たときにパワーで誰が一番強いかと思ったときにいい
このを飛ばしかいいねぇずっと
からちゃったその二つちょっとそうたとケーキがだけでやってたってそんな
達するというかフィジカル的なぶつけ第二もで気軽でもうこれは池なら鍵付きかなと
思って聞いてみたところ
設定感じますよと思います市税長さも天使変種と戦えるわけじゃなくて二次審査の書類
変更感あって4月に受診者で今から面接と実技みたいな感じで
のがあるんで今日た分の面接と実技がだろう中で行われるのかなと思っております今日
で後輩 vs を出すかは選手ができるかどうかがかかっているので是非私も買って
欲しいと思いますマジで僕シーンが来たことないから知ろうと思ってそこ時間
カップを代表してんっ
気持ちてます
ここでやるかやるから店へと思いますやつよどうだからこれ見てきては研究はここ1
週間夏も涙を流すような厳しい厳しいトレーニングにいたい切って今この場にいるわけ
なんで
これは全部見てきた頑張ってきにょんだぞ
何もやってないんだけどね最後にミッキーアイルでもじゃあ
レザーバッハ
くれん
会長けど z 中でそんで強そうな人ばっかりなんすけど
ご覧くださいあそこに見えるのがこれ
俺笹の機体の不正アプリとか負けないよねはベタに負け休みがいえーい
という風に言っています
give me
はございません
toranoana
me
ええええええ
ブーバーし
ああああああ
いいいいいいいいいいいいいい
入ってるけど良いは面接です
ずっとどうこうじゃなくてきも釣っているところでどこまでも今日伝えるから大事だと
思います
きょんちゃんと負けてないと思うんだやっぱり
食べちゃってるー
前方すごくお願いしました21歳で身長か171センチで体重がえっなんかするん
敵地で応募させてもらったのは自分がどれくらいできるかなと何も僕新曲しようじゃ
なくて練習も全く次第で
ここまで実施とりあえずところに中かけろ
んで試してみようかなと思い
ていましたでパラ会は中で
で
と同じ目線で
bejean ん
両方0
狭い部分できたら切ら
思ってます
宜しくお願いしますうぇい
イザハー
いい回りキャリイみんなガッツペイバーさよなちょっと10敗だけど
禁止に先生がその動画に入ってるめちゃめちゃもや面白い
いろんなゆなかとちょっと洋風でずっとチェッカー申します
ちょっ w h
uh
皆さんはございません
それではアクションを開けました
一眼輸送土産多分皆さん
jr
ええええええ
me
有力なんですかな y 校
tl
ブーバーたロスもう高校んときパチュリー
入ったれているわけですね3発当たり具合がバラけてここからよアイドルで続いては
スパーリング先行です
俺何もしないんだけど a
uh
# e
すっごい車
んいいとうううう
ありがとうございます
ね
amaran
3種
me
wh
なるんですよ本当に本当に馬ですねまじこいつです
me
goo
とれません
ash van
まずこれ
ええええええ
付
ています
下さる当たりません
ていた
deni
ええええええ
me
tan
car ん
ええええええ
me
dj
wh
amaran
ni
voodoo
ru 本
ええええええええええ
me
われ
生産性
が入って坊入ったんだ
ええええええ
ん
ポイントデー
ボルボ
まあ基本的よああああ
ん
car
ana
dj ん
dje し野党やセミナー課題とか自分の中で見つかりました
時でもやるだけで決める初めからそのあたりも含めてセミ朝マニアのご連絡をさせて
頂ければと思っておりますのでよろしくお願いします本日はございました
[拍手]
なおなんだよはい戦2敗とか君のもなんだけど
はいっ草田さんよはいこれ
はい
大阪オーディションえっ
今回あの
キリンなの結果ですねえっ
限定版には yeah
yeah
うん
ん
で合格いう形で
その後のスケジュールとかって何かありますかね
はあの後カットがみなぎるように越冬なかったかって
わかりました
あっ皆無ですかー
明日から頑張りますこの7人の南部に誰くる街で
まあ全くわかんないけど訴えるべきだった
飛び出すじゃあおめでとうございます
[音楽]
ブーブー感あるんでアーマーでも選択車もうこの日あがクロス
どんなにあの試合3で分かったと思うんだけど今叶え方がでコーナーでスパ
こーゆーか明確してるんでちょっと1週間これをざっとってウザかったよ
[音楽]
なんで俺会社が動画安売りマスターしてるわけで限界がんばってみよう館できる海外も
ありません
[音楽]
yeah
ていた
[音楽]
カフェ
えっオス化しません
ああああああああ
かな敗戦
俺除く10はボディーロゼちゃん0